thank you so much for joining us here at
11 o'clock i'm christian casares tonight
we're learning more about the man who
was shot and killed this weekend at a
bus stop this as police say they've
arrested the person who pulled the
trigger orco mana joins us live near
paradise and sahara with what he's found
out this evening orca good evening to
you
well christian police say jatoni zendel
was shot near this bus stop after
getting into a fight with two men who
were laughing at him
while they were all on the same bus
together tonight his friend tells me she
is heartbroken and she just wants
justice
everywhere he went everybody considered
him family toya long is holding on to
the memories of her friend jatoni zandel
she describes the 27 year old
affectionately nicknamed jet has a
beautiful soul they met while working at
big chicken where jet was a bartender
jet
was just a bright light that's why she's
shocked jett was shot and killed sunday
night who
who would do such a thing to such a nice
guy he doesn't deserve this metro police
arrested this man 22-year-old john kirby
on a murder charge according to an
arrest report obtained by 8 news now
while jet was riding an rtc bus he
yelled to the bus driver he pressed the
button for the wrong stop a woman then
yelled at jet and told him to walk
that's when a man who was with kirby
started to loudly laugh the report
states the three men got off the bus at
paradise and sahara to fight and jet
threw a punch at kirby who then shot jet
in the chest jett died at the hospital i
don't really
see jett confronting anybody unless it's
self-defense as jet's friends grapple
with grief they want to honor his life
and legacy i want jet to be remembered
as the charismatic funny
loving guy that he always was
police were able to piece together what
happened because of rtc bus surveillance
footage the rtc sent me a statement
today saying public safety is their top
priority and that they've invested more
than 21 million dollars in safety and
security enhancements including live
looking features and security officers
now the suspect in this case john kirby
is due in court on monday reporting live
in las vegas tonight orca mana live
local now